[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
hide and seek with the documents of
course he was obstructing not just the
Department of Justice but his own
attorney from the church he stole
documents he probably is going to be
charged with the Espionage I don't know
who knows if he'll be charged with
Espionage it does seem like he wanted to
make sure even his attorney didn't know
that he had these documents for whatever
reason he had these documents for it
just seems a little peculiar that he
would get at golf tournaments from
Saudis
I don't know maybe the few things are
have to do with each other I think Jack
Smith's gonna find out
we're finding out this morning the
Corcoran his attorney was not allowed to
search his office now it is unclear in
the report from the guardian
of who was
not letting Corcoran Search Donald
Trump's office was it Donald Trump or
was it his staff
who was directing Corcoran not to search
his office where the documents were
found
again I this isn't surprising right are
you surprised that he's obstructing
justice even obstructing his own [__]
attorney misleading his attorney like
this is 101 Donald Trump right I mean am
I [__] crazy here I don't think so
the craziest part about the whole thing
is that they're St they're going to
nominate him for this
like this is the reason why they're
gonna nominate him
we we watched over the weekend as the
Attorney General in Texas the criminal
Republican which they're all criminals
at this point at least it seems that way
what am I out what else am I supposed to
think
the criminal attorney general of Texas
is impeached and suspended while Donald
Trump and Donald Trump's criminal allies
back the Attorney General Paxton of
course they do this two-tier justice
system
that Maga has been bitching about it
exists
we all know that the two-tier justice
system exists they're just really
[__] frightened Maga that the
two-tier justice system the tier that
that is so long protected them is not
going to protect them anymore that's
what they're terrified of Marjorie
Taylor green and the rest of them Ted
Cruz Josh Hawley Donald Trump they're
terrified that that second tier will no
longer
protect them
now this morning I guess Donald Trump
puts out a statement also that he's he's
going to sign an executive order okay
really okay yeah all right all right
he's gonna sign an executive order
denying U.S citizenship to children who
are born in the United States
Birthright he's gonna sign it away no
longer can you be a brown person and be
born here and become an American citizen
only white people I mean that's not
exactly what he's saying but hey you
know the sentiment is there the dog
whistle is there for his supporters
why do you think why do you think
they're going to elect him
because he's a [__] crooked criminal
and he'll do whatever they [__] wish
even if it's against the Constitution
they don't give a [__] that's the that's
the [__] feature of their hatred it's
not like a side effect
okay that's the whole thing
people are talking about the Trump bucks
thing and we'll get to that we'll get to
that there's there's substance here the
other substance about the Ken Paxton
thing
uh this morning and there was a clip
that came up from Steve bannon's Trader
TV news network broadcast got it you
know which one I'm talking about
of Ken Paxton saying that he stopped two
and a half million mail-in ballots
he stopped two and a half did you hear
me two and a half
million mail-in ballots now Donald Trump
won Texas by about 600 000 Ken Paxton
claims that this in this clip that
because he stopped these mail-in ballots
that Biden it's what caused Biden to
lose Texas huh that seems rigged it
seems like a rigged election I don't
know what about you now here's the thing
here's the thing
is I really take what Ken Paxton says
with a grain of salt right this guy's
[__] delusional I mean he's not
tethered or any type of reality
whatsoever
this guy just thought he could run
around doing whatever saying whatever
telling whatever [__] lies he wanted
to
so at face value I don't even know if
Ken Paxton knows the truth about two and
a half million ballots but if it's true
if this is true it feels like to me that
he's admitting to Crime right out in the
open doesn't it to you I mean to me
sounds like he's like yeah we stole the
[__] election and what are you gonna
do about it
okay all right man you guys keep going
with that whole election Integrity
election is rig type [__] when you're
rigging elections that's what the
Attorney General
who is just impeached and suspended by
the Republican party in Texas yeah it
couldn't happen without the Republicans
[__]
he admitted to Aunt Steve bannon's
Trader TV News Network
hell boy I mean you know the news just
keeps going on and on and on and on
but really if we think about
um Donald Trump
and him playing hide and seek with the
classified documents because that's
apparently what was going on they were
they were having practice runs and dress
rehearsals on how they would move these
documents how he would make sure he'd
secured the ones that he wanted to
secure and keep the ones he wanted it
almost feels like he thought there were
documents that were worth more money
than others why how does it feel to you
um
that's what it feels like to me
is that
there were documents that were worth
more money to some unknown Saudi people
who are going to give him a golf
tournament at his golf courses it was
going to be worth way more to them than
the other ones
right
you know that's Espionage right you know
that's what that is that's [__]
Espionage that's [__] treason
can you can you even okay think about
this for a second right okay let's just
let's just let's just play this out a
bit right all right the same
[__] that are terrified of
rainbows on kids clothes right
the same [__] that are gonna
that are gonna boycott Chick-fil-A now
because a Dei I'm not [__] you
that's news this morning too they're
gonna [__] boycott chick they're
gonna boycott everything they ain't
gonna have [__] nothing left by the
time this is over with they're just
gonna be sitting in a tent somewhere
just [__] crying their eyes out
because they can't they can't buy
anything they can't use anything they
can't wear any [__] clothes
whatsoever they can't support any
candidate or any company because they've
all done pride month before in the past
or they got Dei now oh my God oh God oh
it's gonna affect their sensibility
Jesus [__] Christ you goddamn
snowflakes you fascist [__]
snowflakes buck up gross set of nuts and
just get over it a bit Jesus Christ
anyways
these same [__] are gonna watch
Donald Trump possibly possibly get
charged with Espionage because he was
stealing documents to sell them to
Saudis for golf tournaments and they're
gonna be like yeah [__] yeah that's my
guy that's my guy just like they are
with Ken Paxton they're like yeah that's
my [__] guy I like my politicians to
be criminals I like my politicians to
steal elections I like my politicians to
[__] to be a treasonous piece of [__]
that's what we want our Republican
politicians to be they're gonna cheer
him on for this
you [__] doubt me I'm telling you and
then there's supposed to be some kind of
Republican debate in August or some [__]
this [__] ain't gonna show up to
that he ain't gonna show up [__] no it
wouldn't be in his favor actually to
tell you the honest truth to watch all
these other [__] chuckleheads
standing on stage at one after one after
one after one [__] giving him
fellatio and then trying to say that
he's not [__] qualified is gonna be
beautiful and it is only gonna Propel
Donald Trump towards the nomination when
he's not standing on stage with these
[__] chuckleheads it's gonna be
beautiful folks and we're gonna get all
kinds of entertainment do you have much
content we're gonna get out of these
[__] clips
do you know how many hours of the Tony
Michaels podcast we're gonna be able to
do just off of just off a handful of
clips
from these debates of non-donald trump
Republicans standing on stage acting
like they love him but they hate him at
the same time think about he's gonna
pack the audience full people who are
gonna boo them every time they some say
something bad about Trump
[__] mark my words you don't you
think I'm [__] lying you just hide
and watch
so he's going to be indicted
for documents stealing them and selling
them that's [__] that's what it is get
the [__] out of here you you can't
convince me otherwise I mean yeah he
stole documents to cover up January 6th
and his his attempt to overthrow the
government but it's money it's always
100 about money because the guy's
[__] broke and he's constantly
looking for a way to convince his
supporters that he's rich
all the while he's asking them for
[__] money to pay for [__] legal
bills because he committed crime to try
to get more money
yeah but they're going to propel him to
the nomination
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
it's gonna happen
it's it's gonna be weird
and the rest of the country the majority
of the country who don't give a [__]
right they don't care I mean yeah we
care here right and there's a certain
percentage on the country that gives a
[__] about the the government we give a
[__] about our democracy we give a [__]
about our institutions but it's not a
high number I hate to disappoint you
it's it's about the same number is that
people who [__] are Maga right
there's about 12 13 maybe at best that
are manga there's about 12 maybe 15
percent uh maybe up to 20 that actually
give a damn on a day-to-day basis about
our democracy and about our institutions
of our democracy the rest of the people
in the country that other sixty percent
65 percent don't give a [__]
they don't care and frankly they don't
want to hear about Donald Trump anymore
they don't want to hear about them from
us the people who [__] hate his guts
and can't wait for him to get receive
any sort of accountability but they
definitely definitely can't stand the
[__] that love him oh my God
they [__] hate those sons of [__]
they're tired of hearing about him but
it doesn't matter they're going to
nominate him that's why Joe Biden I
think is going to win by 15 million
votes mark it down May 30th Tuesday 12
14 p.m eastern time Tony Michaels says
yes Joe Biden will receive 15 million
more votes than Donald Trump in 2024.
that's it
because they're gonna go vote against
this piece of sludge
but the moglodytes don't care they don't
care they want him they need him he he
is the reason he is the reason that
keeps them in in their cycle of hatred
in their cycle of bigotry he's given
them permission to do it
I'll tell you a story we went to Target
last night go shopping
and we happened upon the pride section
and we were deeply offended by the Satan
I'm just kidding listen it's in the
seasonal part of Target right they got
The Upfront there's the seasonal part
where they put like Christmas Easter
Fourth of July all the [__] seasonal
[__] right so they put the pride stuff
there we went in we looked around oh my
God it was horrible oh my God the
pornography I'm just kidding again the
one thing that was hilarious is there's
this little outfit this little baby out
there it's like like uh like overalls
they were black overalls right like a
shorts overalls outfit it had a rainbow
on it okay are you following me for the
Satan for the Satanist out there listen
up good there's a rainbow on it and
underneath the rainbow guess what it
said
it said be kind
oh my God how dare they indoctrinate
children be nice to each other what the
[__] are they yammering about there
wasn't anything anything in that display
that was offensive I mean not to me but
I mean offensive in general I mean there
was one sweater that said live laugh
lesbian but man if you're [__] if you
are offended by the word lesbian on a
shirt
this is America it's 2023 and you think
it's satanic
and it's indoctrination to have the word
lesbian on an adult sweatshirt get the
[__] out of here you people were
printing [__] that [__] on Hillary
Clinton's shirts [__] Hillary Clinton
Locker the [__] up [__] that [__] Trump
that [__] on shirts and wearing them
around in public get the [__] out of
here you you offended my [__] ass you
people are dumb as dog [__] I'm not
kidding you there was a goddamn baby's
outfit that had a rainbow and it said be
kind
be kind underneath the rainbow
that's what they're offended about
laugh at them mock them these are the
same [__] that are going to
nominate
of a [__] treasonous piece of [__]
who try to overthrow our government and
then after trying to overthrow it when
he still couldn't pitcher fit and win
and his [__] violent domestic
terrorist followers couldn't [__]
Force the Congress to make him king of
our country and rip up and [__] on our
constitution he stole documents to make
sure that he could secure a golf
tournament at his [__] golf golf
courses from Saudi Arabia that's what it
is [__] them I'm saying it right here
right out in the open I don't give a
[__] that's what it is
it has to do with money it has to
I mean he lost all power right he wasn't
going to be president he knew that [__]
he knew he [__] lost back in November
he knew he lost they told him over and
over and over again you [__] lost you
[__] lost there's no way you can win
you're not gonna win this Joe Biden won
they kept telling him and he kept going
and he kept going then he begged he
begged the proud boys and he begged The
Oath Keepers and he begged his redneck
[__] followers to come to Washington
and to save him
and then he told them to march down on
the Capitol and commit violence and
overturn the [__] government because
he didn't get his way and Mike Pence
won't do it [__] him too hang him as
well that's what the [__] they did
that's what the [__] happened
and after he still didn't get his way he
stole our [__] documents to sell them
to the Saudis for his stupid little
[__] golf tournaments cause the
[__] is broke
he's broke as a [__] joke since the
early 90s this [__] has been
stealing money and laundering money to
pretend to be rich and he's not just
like he pretends to be smart just like
he pretended to be president just like
he's pretending now that he's running
just to help the country he's helping
him [__] self
and if you don't know that you were a
dumb [__]
so good nominate him you dumb sons of
[__] as if you have anyone better
anyways
who else do you have Rhonda santis get
the [__] out of here
the guy the guy can't even [__] the guy
couldn't work his way out of a wet paper
sack the [__] doesn't even know
that his downfall is his stupid [__]
war on wokism even Kevin McCarthy this
morning is starting to Parrot this [__]
parrot this [__] on you you Hewitt's
[__] broadcast it's gonna be their
downfall no one gives a flying [__] in
this country if you're offended by
wokeness they don't give a [__]
Stop Believing these [__]
they don't care they don't give a [__]
about Bud Light and if they do give a
[__] about Bud Light or Target or
Chick-fil-A they're [__] part of the
cult
they've been brainwashed
and they're a hateful [__]
anyways
so [__] them write them off it's enough
of this [__] just ignore the [__] out of
them and let's move on
but they're not gonna let us
and the reason why is because they they
have no principle they have no
Foundation of any policy they have no
beliefs left anymore
none
they're gonna they're gonna boycott
Chick-fil-A hate [__] the
wokers the motherwokers boycotted
Chick-fil-A long time ago because
Chick-fil-A was given money to
anti-lgbtq organizations you dumb sons
of [__]
what the [__] are you talking about and
listen boycott everything go ahead do it
look like fools because boycotts listen
to me listen real good
turn the [__] volume up if you hate
me or if you love to hate me one of the
way and they're kind of the same but if
you [__] hate my voice and you hate
my guts turn it up I'm gonna tell you
something you don't [__] know I'll
tell the left something they don't know
the left doesn't know this either
they're dumb [__] with this
[__] boycotts got it boycotts don't work
they don't work
they don't shame Works boycotts don't
work
shame is what works for corporations
that's what they get scared of is shame
not boycotts they don't give a [__]
about boycotts it's free advertising for
them dummies
they're in the news over and over and
over and over again you don't think it
increases their sales come on man
why do why do you think gun
manufacturers love [__] mass
shootings
you would think that gun manufacturers
like oh the machines are bad no it's
good for gun sales
that's right they sit around in rooms
[__] they sit around in rooms
and they're they're like man oh man we
had we goddamn we have 45 mass shootings
this month sales were up high five with
who
you [__] doubt me they're sitting in
boardrooms right now handfuls of
families in this country making
gazillions dollars of profit of blood
money from Republicans because they keep
the gun laws lacked so that there can be
mass shootings so that people are
terrified they're gonna take your guns
so you go buy more of them after every
mass shooting they discovered this in
the late 90s
they discovered it in the late 90s
you guys remember you you guys you
remember the the high school shooting
Columbine
Wayne lot payer Wayne lapair went to
Congress
to lobby for more gun restrictions
and all of a sudden the gun lobby
tucked-tailed and run away from that the
NRA ran away from that you know why
they found out in the data that when
there's mass shootings there's an
increase in gun sales
because the people who buy guns the
people who believe that guns will
protect you and I can protect myself
from government
with my guns
those dumb [__]
when they see a mass shooting they get
scared because they're cowards they're
weak and they go buy more guns because
they think it makes them [__] tough
it's the same stupid [__] with a boycott
it's the same dumb [__]
boycotts don't work listen to me stop
doing it stop saying it
boycotts don't work they don't [__]
work they're not gonna work that isn't
how Market pressure works anyways it's
called Shame you have to shame these
[__]
that's what you have to do and it's hard
as [__] to shame some of these
corporations because they really don't
have any
like the gun manufacturers
the Republican party is another entity
that has no [__] shame left at all
why do you think they're all like yeah
Ken Paxton he's a criminal we love him
we love him oh man we love us some
criminal attorney general in Texas [__]
let's vote for him hell yeah hell I mean
the guy was on indictments
and they [__] voted for him
and he's so untethered from reality
again this whole 2 million [__]
mail-in ballot [__] that he's talking
about I don't know if there's any truth
to it we're gonna ask Texas all day
because it's [__] Tuesday you know
that
we're gonna see what he thinks about
this two million ballots that Ken Paxton
say his he stopped so that way Joe Biden
didn't win Texas what what that seems
like that seems like it rigged an
election but here's the thing is my
belief is is that [__] Ken Paxton is
so untethered from reality probably
doesn't even know the [__] he didn't
know [__] from Shinola
he don't know his head from a hole in
the ground his ass from a hole in the
ground he'll stick it up in there he'll
really get it in there all the way
shoulder deep
but I don't I don't think I don't know
if he knows what he's talking about
that's why the Republicans like this
guy's gotta go and this guy he's he's a
he's lost his [__] marbles now his
marbles pack their [__] and they left
they had enough of Ken Paxton [__]
whoo baby am I on a roll this morning am
I on a roll I got news for you I got uh
great news for you guess what guess what
as they all step on these rakes
as they do this professional rake
stepping that they truly truly love we
have the merch for you here at the Tony
Michaels podcast that's right we got
t-shirts this afternoon we'll have more
items I think we'll do a hoodie we'll
put some more stuff up but we got
t-shirts right now let them eat rake
t-shirts are now on sale go to store.the
Tony michaels.com that store that the
tonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com click the merch
store
you'll find let them eat rake in the
merch store don't forget to go get you
some let them eat rake there's been
several people already
order their t-shirts well we'll put some
more stuff up there we'll get some like
hoodies and
um some other things yeah like stickers
a lot of people like the stickers that'd
be perfect put that sticker on your uh
on your Trump loving
uncle's [__] bathroom mirror [__] on
his truck yeah the backless truck just
stick it right on there [__] them
so you'll be able to order those
stickers so I get some stickers up today
I'll get some other stuff up today oh
boy oh boy also don't forget don't
forget to subscribe while you're here on
YouTube you're not going to want to miss
a single episode but today's Tuesday
it's Taco Tuesday in Texas Paul Tuesday
Nexus Paul is going to be joining us
make sure you follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod and download every
single episode on Apple Spotify and
Google you know another good place to
watch
this show if you have a Facebook account
it's Facebook just go to at the Tony
Michaels that's at the Tony Michaels you
can watch us every single weekday right
there on Facebook if you still have one
of those accounts
you still got one open or you weren't
banned Perma band for life
for saying crazy [__] about the Cheeto
dust queuing on her let's check in on
Twitch what do we got going over there
on Twitch
holy moly you guys are awesome yesterday
we had our subscriptions were down
because people hadn't renewed their
subscription
but if you follow us on Twitch it's free
okay but if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can link your Prime account
to your Twitch account okay
and then you give us that one free
subscription because it costs money for
a subscription on Twitch give us that
one free subscription you get with your
Prime account
when you link your Twitch account to
your Prime account and we will get a few
dollars every month and it won't cost
you a single extra nickel
here's how to do it
our great moderator Mighty librarian has
given directions she made directions
online that's right
she made directions on how to link your
Prime account to your Twitch account
just go down in the description right
here on YouTube go down in the
description it's the link there or you
can go to thetonymichaels.com I changed
the link where it says link Amazon and
twitch to her instructions it's
beautiful it's simple it's easy you can
find it right there find exactly how to
do it
and re-subscribing is either even easier
so go now link your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account give us that few
extra dollars that doesn't cost you a
single nickel every month we appreciate
all the support here on the Tony
Michaels podcast the most important
support is you coming and watching every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific live
live don't go anywhere we got Texas Paul
when we come back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome
back to the show it's Tuesday Tuesday
Tuesday
Texas Tuesday we're going to talk about
the Texas Attorney criminal General
ah I'm gonna see if Jenkins ball thinks
this [__] is going to be removed
or not
uh from from his office that he was
elected for it's crazy this clip this
morning of him so a lot of spring in
Texas well it's not waste any more time
Texas Paul how are you this morning my
friend how's it going I am wonderful my
friend as always I'm excited to be here
great always good to see your bright
shining face I like I man I was on fire
this morning and I do it with some heat
this morning I I had it going what do
you what do you what do you what do you
make of this um I mean it's not
surprising to me that Trump was boxing
out his attorney to go search for these
documents obviously he's not only hiding
something from the government but he was
hiding something from his attorneys and
the reason why is because he know he
knows he broke the law he knows he knows
he should not have had these documents
or doing what he was doing with these
documents or what he was going to do
with these documents it's clear you
wouldn't hide it from your attorney
because you would assume that you would
have attorney-client privilege but if
you know that you're committing crimes
in your in your coercing your [__]
attorney to commit crimes it's no longer
going to give you the privilege of
attorney client it's going to fall and
that's what the [__] he knows that's why
it's so important this morning this
story now
um again there's there's gonna be a lot
of [__] speculation here and a lot of
people are saying that that Jack Smith
has reached the end of his documents
investigation he's going to indict I
actually don't quite believe that most
of these leaks are going to be coming
out of the Trump Camp anyways and I
believe the Trump Camp is actually
trying to get people to believe he's
going to be indicted that way he won't
be indicted he won't be indicted he
won't be indicted he won't be indicted
and they'll continue the stupid
narrative that it's all Witch Hunt and
[__] like that that's actually my
opinion that I think Jack Smith isn't
isn't a week away from indicting Donald
Trump
um I I just don't believe that because
that that would have to make me believe
that the leaks that are coming out of
the Trump camp and the Trump side
because I would imagine that Jack Smith
and the government is keeping their case
tight to the chest what do you think
about that whole part of it
you're muted
I apologies I always do that I'm sorry
man
right what specifically are you asking
me about is he going to be indicted or
is he well well I know he's going to be
indicted here there's no question it's a
[__] obstruction and if he's not
indicted then the country's over as we
know it I mean that's just that's just
pure and simple fact here someone isn't
held accountable for what he was doing
by hiding these documents from his
[__] attorney there's a reason for it
but what I'm asking is because everyone
keeps saying Jack Smith's at the end of
the road the document's case he's going
to indict I actually don't believe that
I I believe that that Jack Smith and the
prosecution is holding their case tight
to the chest and these leaks are the
Trump camp and Trump and the Trump Camp
are trying to convince people oh it's
going to be next week oh it's going to
be next week that way when he's not
indicted this week not indicted next
week and then they can keep saying see
it's all Witch Hunt he was supposed to
be indicted the the media was reporting
he's getting by night and he's not it's
all Witch Hunt that that's more
advancement of that [__] narrative in
my belief in my estimation what's your
opinion on when Jack Smith's gonna
[__] put the put the hammer to the
head of the nail here on Trump's coffin
soon soon I think it will be July at the
latest but not next week there was the
heaven week right but not next week
because I don't think it's that early
[__] that's way too hard it could come
early July I don't know they've been
very tight to the vest all the
machinations the the Jack Smith and his
office has gone through you're right the
leaks have not come from him anywhere so
I would be guessing if I said all we can
look at is what's happened around and
like you said that that hearing over
Evan Corcoran was huge a lot of really
smart people have been saying that was
the last hitch in the wall
um you know
his own attorney being told okay you've
got to you've got to cooperate with Jack
Smith
people were saying that was it that that
was the last thing all that's left is
put the case in order and then pull the
trigger
um
we haven't heard any new Revelations per
se about oh now Jack Smith is looking at
this Jack Smith is looking at that oh
this thing got opened up he's looking at
this over here it's it's been pretty
much well everybody in unison that that
is in the know that that that are that
have contacts within the doj have been
saying
this is wrapped up it's done so
how long it takes them to actually pull
the trigger on it I don't know I don't
know exactly how long how much I don't
know how much of a case he has
which I think is going to be it's going
to be much broader than just the
documents I believe I a lot of people
have speculated it'll just be the
documents case because you know we just
had the Revelation the other day that
that as soon as the the archives gave
him the order to surrender the documents
because yeah folks if you're not if
you're not aware Trump lost his
clearance the second he left office
he lost they they took his clearance
immediately they said he's a danger to
the country unlike for other former
presidents that might be worth them
keeping their clearance because they can
offer some sort of counsel to a current
current Administration and we've and
we've seen that before where a former
president will get involved in like
maybe a negotiation
um over returning someone home or
something like that because of the
relationships and the stuff that they
know and and and some of the foreign
policy and that they had and those
relationships
um where a former president or or Allies
or or Liaisons of the former presidents
can go help the United States and a lot
of times it has to do with getting
someone home from a country where
they're you know not exactly the
Brittany Greiner situation but in some
other situations or negotiating like a
deal like a nuclear deal with Iran and
and so on and and so forth you know
these things are crucial
um where former presidents who can make
a difference for the United States keep
their clearance but this guy's not going
to make a difference for the United
States he's a danger to the United
States not a help right I mean that's
what you're saying
yeah and and I can give you an even more
immediate example of how this worked out
um the UK bucked us we were limiting
what offensive Weaponry we were given to
the Ukraine
the UK said nah screw this this is our
continent this isn't going to happen in
your backyard we think Ukraine should
have our Storm Shadow cruise missiles
because Russia is just bombing the [__]
out of them indiscriminately and we need
to give the Ukraine the ability to fire
back we were like no no that is too far
Ukraine is hot or you know rightfully so
they're going to hit inside Russia this
is going to escalate do not do that what
happened was you had people that were
formerly in the government in the UK
meet with people that were formerly in
the government here in the U.S they
talked about it so that back channels
could be utilized rather than making
this a big
split you know what I'm saying this this
wasn't going to be uh in your face we're
disagreeing on something it was all
about Channel communication and UK made
their case won the argument and said no
they need these they really need these
and they got them I mean that's that's a
more present example of how this stuff
works Trump will never ever ever in his
lifetime be involved in any conversation
like that because the only people's
balls he ever sucked were freaking
dictators
and why do you need a guy to talk to a
dictator who do you need going to talk
to Kim Jong-un we're not going to
negotiate with Kim Jong-un anyways we're
not well speaking of Vladimir Putin in
Russia and that's another piece of news
that we can talk about later on today or
we can talk about it right now is
apparently
um Vladimir it seems Vladimir Putin is
attacking his own country attacking
Moscow with drones to try to drum up
support for the war
um which is you know on on course for
Putin it only it only smells of
desperation of Putin that he's trying to
bomb his own people and kill his own
people so that he can try to convince
him that it's Ukraine to get them to
support the war it just it just it it it
it lays out his desperation here and
that um Vladimir Putin's days are are
numbered which they were numbered the
minute he entered Ukraine
um but you know I guess we can talk
about that a little bit later so I wanna
want to go to
and ask you about this attorney general
part or this impeachment in your state
because this has been a long time coming
right this is not this is not something
that that people could not predict that
he was going to be in this in this
situation so let's talk about it because
I'm watching it over the weekend watched
some of the clips and but I want to get
your take on the on the impeachment and
the suspension and and then
um not only that but
the reaction that Ken Paxton and the
Trump allies have had I'm gonna bring in
Gabe Sanchez uh while we talk about this
um good morning sunshine yeah
um so so give us give us your take on
because you're right there in Texas uh
you actually had the chance to to not
vote for Ken Paxton uh on a ballot so
tell us in Texas what's the feeling
there and like what what happened over
the weekend tell us actually what
happened
version of what happened
you have a civil war going on here in
Texas you've got the DeSantis Camp
you've got the Trump camp
Greg Abbott used to be Trump Camp he
turned sides he's all on
he's all pro DeSantis right now
you have wait right by the name wait
wait wait I want to make sure we Define
this so it's Maga versus Geck is that
what it is Maga versus gak okay that is
a huge huge portion of it you've got a
guy by the name of Dade Fallon who is
the speaker of the house he was put in
place by an oligarch here in Texas by
the name of Tim Dunn I'll tell you about
him later on but on another show I can I
can do a whole show on Tim Dunn but he
was put in place by Tim Dunn he is a a
puppet of Tim Dunn
[Music]
is DeSantis
you've got Ken Paxton who is
rabidly Trump
they have been going at each other
behind the scenes Ken Paxton has been in
a lot of legal trouble he embarrassed
himself he had a mistress down in San
Antonio he didn't want to drive two and
a half hours to get his carrot wet so he
got her a job in Austin
so he could get his freak on in Austin
is that what did you hear what means
like getting carrots wet that makes them
more delicious is that what you I don't
know I I don't cook a lot of carrots
what's the
yeah okay man any way you want to put it
he was
just put your time you're talking about
mud for his Turtle that's what we said
we say yeah mud for his turtle okay go
ahead okay go ahead sorry I was confused
I thought we were so you've got this
you've got this backdrop of behind the
scenes battling going on
Dade Fallon's people went to Ken Paxton
and said hey dude
you can't do this
this is too easy for people to
understand you got a guy by the name of
Neil Paul a real estate investor here in
the state of Texas to fund your
girlfriend's boinking here
people get that
okay if you do this we're gonna take you
out
so Ken Paxton
being Ken Paxton the megalomaniac Trump
supporter he is said I'm Kim Paxton the
federal government hasn't been able to
take me down nobody in the Republican
party has been been able to take me down
the Democrats haven't been able to take
me down I can do whatever the hell I
want and I'll show you because I'm going
to take you out and he was the one that
actually drew first blood against Dade
Fallon Dade Fallon showed up on the
floor
of our Texas Congress
drunk as a skunk
I mean hammered he had to hold himself
up with one hand while he swung the
gavel and he was shocking like this and
we're going to go ahead and bring this
before the committee you know I mean he
was just lit
so Ken Paxton calls on his resignation I
mean he goes public with it that's that
and the other it's a humiliation makes
it a big spectacle Dade Fallon turns
around and Shanks Ken Paxton he says
buddy
you're in the middle of a scandal that
no Republican is going to get behind
I've got enough votes to get this moving
we're going to get articles impeachment
rolling and the rest of the Republican
party went well [__]
what do we do now
do we support the guy that's you know
given the high Hard One to just to his
mistress here that everybody's going to
understand this everybody gets this one
how many ways can you say schlubbing I
mean you yeah you've had several we've
had several different ways here that you
said schlubbing now let's see it was wax
the carrot we have mudbirds no no no not
wax the carrot it was good get your
carrot wet yeah yeah okay okay wax the
gear is a different thing you want to
Wick get the anyway
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just I'm I'm
maybe I'm concentrating on the wrong
thing here maybe I'm off focus here but
I'm monkey balling stinky winking I mean
I mean they really are right okay but
anyways so Republicans went well [__]
yeah
Ken Paxton you lose you've been a scab
on our party for eight years you have
been a source for Democrats to call us
corrupt
um screw you you're out and they voted
121 I believe to 23 to impeach and then
which immediately One Way Texas got
something right was that if you're
impeached in the state of Texas we don't
allow you to use your office to
retaliate and fight that impeachment so
he was immediately suspended from Office
meaning he's still the Attorney General
but he does not have the powers of the
Office of the Attorney General doesn't
even have the keys right can't get in
his own office he has to stay the hell
away he cannot he's out he is out I just
I I I honestly I just love the fact
because we were talking about this last
week and I was I was like my sneaking
suspicion is that Paxton going after
feeling this is feeling's attempt to get
back at Paxton and that's this is my
question on on the show last week I was
like I don't I was like he's not in the
committee but I feel like he's pulling
the strings from the background to get
back at Paxton and some people in the
chat were like no no he wasn't like he's
not in the committee he's not involved
and I was like I don't know these events
are too close together it feels like
one's going after the other
and here we go my question is how how
much how I mean it it anytime I've seen
Kim Paxton in an interview and I'm going
to show the interview with Steve Ben and
you're on the trader TV News Network do
we know is that from is that interview
from this year I don't know it doesn't
seem like this man's hairs looks totally
different he admitted I think this is
from 2021 right but this is the craziest
part is this thing is resurfaced this
this morning after all this [__] [__]
about Ken Paxton the corruption because
I think what happened was it was like oh
he's a [__] liar because Ken Paxton
is a [__] liar I mean just I mean
it's like I mean you think Donald Trump
can lie I mean getting back to his like
hold hold my queer beer here
why would you think it was smart to I
mean like obviously it's two years after
the fact but like why would you think it
was smart to lie about something like
that well I think it was like bragging
like I'm the one who made Donald Trump
win right and I think that's in the
Trump World this is the stupid [__] that
gives them credit like if you're willing
to commit crime for Donald Trump then
you're you're Donald Trump's best buddy
right like Mike Flynn you know good
examples Steve Bannon there's another
example I mean I'm the Roger Stone all
these people who are willing to commit
crime Paul manafort in the name of
Donald Trump are his best friends and
that's you know I mean that's [__]
Trump world that's their MO they think
they're gangsters they're not they're
nincompootin Nazis but here's this clip
let's watch this can you figure out when
this was but here is here's this clip
from uh Steve Bennett you can see Steve
Bannon looks like I'm gonna Target
drinking Bud Light doesn't it look like
that to you I don't know I'm just saying
I think it's from 2021. okay because
that's when they were talking about the
2020 election so you notice after that
right it's after that because if you
look this if you look this story up
about you know 2.5 million votes it the
stories came out in 2021
an important thing about this though
guys is that we just passed that law
here in Texas they've got it on the
books that in Houston in Harris County
that is your
biggest chunk of the democratic vote
they can now willy-nilly throw those
votes out they don't when you're talking
about the impeachment of Ken Paxton that
was one of the nails in his coffin they
don't need Ken Paxton anymore to do this
[__] and FYI guys yeah he really did
this I'll tell you more on the other
side he really did this okay let's let's
listen to what he says about two and a
half million mail-in ballots that Ken
Paxton and he he seems to be personally
claiming he got rid of
um with his power as attorney general to
make sure that Joe Biden wouldn't win
Texas because what he claims here is
that Joe Biden would have listened okay
it's um certainly critical to my state
and that's why we fought off these 12
lawsuits we had them in Houston we had
them in San Antonio we had him in Austin
we had him in the counties where you'd
have the most liberal judges and it was
a concerted effort nationally with lots
of money going into it and just knowing
that we had 12 losses that we had to win
and if we lost one of them we lost
Harris County Trump won by 620 000 votes
in Texas Harris County mail-in ballots
that they wanted to send out were 2.5
million because we're all illegal and we
were able to stop every one of them had
we not done that we would have been in
the very same situation we would have
been on Election night I was watching
election night and I knew when I saw
what was happening in these other states
that that would have been Texas we would
have been in the same boat we would have
been one of those Battleground states
that there were counting votes in Harris
County for three days and Donald Trump
would have lost the election oh so what
he's saying next ball is that if you if
people would have been able to vote and
they would have counted those votes then
then Joe Biden wanted that's what Ken
Paxton is saying let me let me clean
this up okay first of all he says it's
all mail-in ballots that that's a lie
that was wrong that was just the guy's a
drunk okay
he always looks like he's about a half a
second from just passing out I'm not
gonna lie he's like if you ever stand
next to Ken Paxton
one it's you can't look the man in the
eye because you're like which eye you
know I mean yeah but the other thing is
that he is always reeks he and Ronnie
Jackson must have the same boozy Supply
boost supplier because he always smells
of alcohol
that's got to be a cologne that he's
wearing right oh man yeah oh the Jack
Daniels yeah
um
but no she he got the verbiage wrong and
he inflated it by about a hundred
percent but no it really happened the AP
took a look at it and Statewide they
actually they actually rejected 23 000.
mail-in balance okay about 13 all right
that's what they were just Statewide
that Statewide or in Harris County right
okay Statewide say what okay
um doesn't sound like a lot but it's
about 13 okay that's what they just
rejected that came in now they also
rejected people getting ballots see
these are where the lawsuits were coming
in because there were so many things
that the state had done just to make it
difficult to get about it they were you
know doing signature checks and all the
other [__] and you had to follow
these I mean x y z perfectly any step
that you didn't get perfectly right you
didn't get your ballot period
student
it made it really a mess okay that was
just just the mail-in stuff okay they
also
screwed with in-person voting okay and I
want to remind you when he's talking
about defending these lawsuits
he's not the Republican party and he's
not the Texas Republican party he's
using my tax dollars well he said
there's to fight he's saying there's 12
there was 12 lawsuits that they fought
off right right and he used my tax money
to fight on behalf of the Republican
Party
okay he used to keep that in mind that
is my tax money as a Democrat being used
to fight on behalf of the Republican
party and these fights you know had to
do with poll Watchers what they call
poll Watchers where they actually have
training on how to intimidate people
where they they literally did carve out
about a million to a million and a half
votes
here in Texas
through all of these procedures that
they put in place so he's not lying he's
really not lying he used the force and
power of his office to make sure that
the Republican Party could do
disgusting crap and do it under the
guise of the law which ties the hands of
of the fed you know the the doj the you
know the the
FEC can't do [__] about it
because it's the law
so when you get a situation like that
you have nothing but voter advocacy
groups and the Democratic party that can
sue
he uses the fact that we're questioning
a law in place to step in for the
Republican party and Sue
that I mean that's the long and short of
it and yes you remembered this and yes
it was really about people say how could
you how could you people vote for gray
habit how could you people vote for
Trump we didn't
we didn't
I keep telling people there are more
people like me than there are them
believe me and Ken Paxton just told you
I mean he just told you straight out of
his mouth he used his office he used his
power to derail people voting in the
state of Texas whose votes he did not
want counted
that's the fight we're having here that
I mean that that's it it's not an
ideological battle we think these Pricks
and targets are Pricks we don't like
these freaking people here in Texas the
vast majority of us don't
but that [__]
uses his office as and and the next one
will too I'm going to tell you the guy
the the Republican that replaces Ken
Paxton if we let into a republican in
there will absolutely do exactly what
Kim Paxton is doing he will be in arm of
the Republican party so let's let's uh
let me ask you this what what is the um
what's the future for Ken Paxton look
like now that he is he's still the
Attorney General but he's no longer has
the keys to the to the to the vehicle in
other words where he can crash it into
everything
um as he's wearing his Ode to Jack
Daniels as you said
um but Ken Paxton is impeached and
suspended so what's the future for Ken
Paxton there in Texas then because he's
got several more years on his term that
he was voted in
yeah he is going to be removed in July
or August
around there
have you have you it's just it's almost
identical to what happens federally he
has been impeached he is now currently
impeached he is suspended from his
office until they can hold a trial which
means the state of Texas does not have
an attorney general right now we have an
acting
they won't want that to continue for
very long
they will hold a trial rather
expeditionally expeditiously they don't
want this to stay in the news cycle
forever you know going into the 2024
elections they're going to try to put
this to bed
July August at the latest
the beautiful thing is here in the state
of Texas you need a majority vote period
simple majority 51 percent
you know you did no super majority and
the math isn't there because I guarantee
you every Democrat is going to be like
[__] yes
well let me tell you too because I
thought it was I thought it was funny
that um Donald Trump apparently was
making personal phone calls two people
on the floor uh when this impeachment
proceeding was going and and he was
tweeting well posting on fraud social
Ted Cruz was cheating Margaret Taylor
green was between all these treasonous
pieces of [__] of course it shouldn't be
surprising that these treasonous pieces
[__] love getting Paxton right and
they're going to support Kim Paxton
because it him being removed impeached
and removed actually spells out a a a a
narrative
and almost a road map to their demise in
the Republican party but but more than
anything Donald Trump couldn't even stop
this thing right he couldn't stop this
thing so who owns the Republican party
in Texas is it Donald Trump or is it uh
Greg Abbott vis-a-vis de Ron DeSantis
yeah yeah it's putting fingers putting
fingers you're starting down the
government in Texas that's that's
absolutely that's why Greg Abbott Greg
Abbott has he is quieter than a church
mouse right now he is trying that's
great to not let these monkeys yeah the
governor um
my weakling Governor is is terrified
that these monkeys hurling [__] at each
other is going to get him on him
you know Edward brings up a good
question here
um yeah what's gonna happen to his poor
girlfriend like the the the carrot
wetter as you called she's gonna have to
get real jobs what's happening
no man but but seriously they're going
to remove him from office and what will
happen to Ken Paxton is he will open a
law firm here he will do some lobbying
here do you think you'll keep his law
license
oh yeah oh God the state of Texas is
such a [__] I'm sorry that's
pathetic if you if the Texas bar if you
get removed from your office for bribery
and the Texas bar can't go wait a second
wait a second [__] is gonna go
practice not only that but his bribery
obstruction like Amusement handling like
public funds like all of these things
where you're like uh as a city as this
as a person sitting as a representative
as the Attorney General of a whole state
it's like maybe this shouldn't be the
career you have right as a result maybe
you should be an attorney low if you
can't be the Attorney General maybe you
shouldn't be an attorney just in general
the bar association in the state of
Texas is full of right-wing conservative
[__]
Paxton could shoot a secretary from the
bar association
at the front door of the bar association
and the bar association's takeaway would
be
you know Ken Paxton's gonna need his law
license to defend himself in this murder
trial so we really will it would be it
would be political and wrong of us to
disbar him while he is going through
this trial for murdering Denise
she brought great muffins she really did
you know I mean
by the way brain muffins I think they
get a bad rap brand muffins are good but
is that the Republican muffin of choices
brand muffin
I don't know I I mean according to Ken
Paxton it's uh lady muffins
carrot cake muffins apparently okay Gabe
go ahead with your thoughts sorry I
didn't mean to help what I was gonna do
what I was gonna bring up with is uh
he's also he's still he's still under
investigation by the doj so once once he
gets removed from office then he still
has you know still has Merrick Garland's
team to deal with right
no no
they've had eight years to deal with
that they're not going to touch him on
it we just had a settlement in in the
Civil they actually had a civil case
over the matter where he he you know Ken
Paxton was actually on the phone
threatening people
while he was being impeached he was
calling people on the floor threatening
them I've got the dirt on you [__] you
vote against me and I will come for you
and they vote against him anyway they
voted against him anyways because it
seems like it was over seems like he's
done yeah I mean he is done he is done
but [__] I forgot where I was going with
that and Gabe had a great comment and I
just the doj the doj yeah no no yeah
um we just had a civil settlement over
that where I'm gonna have to pay 3.3
million dollars to the whistleblowers
that told everybody in the world that
that Ken Paxton was taking bribes and
arranging bribes and everything
everything else
he fires you know red fires the
whistleblowers attacks the
whistleblowers ruins their lives so they
sue and there's a 3.3 million dollar
civil settlement so everybody knows what
happened
but the doj has no interest they have
not had an interest for eight years
they're not going to do anything about
it now they're just so if Ken Paxton is
removed how long does it take for him to
become Donald Trump's campaign manager
no that that is a great question
actually yeah I don't know
him in federal court against Jack Smith
can you imagine whoa whoa hey hold the
phone hold the phone can you imagine can
you imagine if the Texas bar keeps Ken
Paxton's license and Ken Paxton goes on
to defend Donald Trump in federal court
over [__] documents crimes possible
Espionage I mean I will I will say this
Ken Paxton definitely can have his eyes
on two things at once so he'll be a
great person on how to fight Jack Smith
and anyone else coming at him okay
there's a reason I call him
Jesus Christ
I mean have you ever seen a picture of
the guy he's got he takes a picture and
he's like this
I mean
oh [__] man no but seriously I wonder
how he's going to be involved it
you know Trump
he's a user all he does is use people
Ken Paxton doesn't have a lot to give
him anymore you know he's not like a
Kerry Lake who's still got people
supporting him and whatever wait wait
people supporting her
yeah her yeah yes I said him her oh but
yeah she does in Arizona
crazy ass uncles are still mailing her
money in Arizona
I'm not kidding Kent action doesn't
really have that yeah but they're still
sending her money I don't know she
showed up in a jacket the other day that
said she was the governor on it
what the [__] are you [__] me send me
this I want you guys I want the [__]
evidence okay okay hand it over hand it
over we're gonna show the audience
handed over we'll we'll transition to
carry Lake I don't give a [__] I've seen
this no I have not seen this Nazi in a
fake Governor's jacket what the [__] she
made a jacket that says she's the
governor
right there that's awesome
let me tell you something if if you have
a level of delusion that that leads you
to print [__] on [__] clothing to
make you feel good about [__] you lost
uh more power to you holy [__] that's
that bless her [__] heart you know
what I think I think it reminds me of uh
uh like getting your own jacket with the
governor on there is like saying that
you're the champion it was like she
blocked me I can't look at it hang on
let me let me switch my account let me
switch my game it would be like if you
went to a local like trophy store and
you put like MVP and you're like MVP
Gabe Sanchez and you put it on there and
and you know you put it you put it in
your little display case and you say you
got this award in that award and someone
comes up and like what'd you get that
for and you're like oh
this was five days ago how did I not
know about this okay let's pull this up
Carrie Lake here she's this is her tweet
and I had to pull it up on my other
account because she [__] blocked me
this [__] [__] what a [__] [__]
ass [__] okay she says I'm in this
fight to save Arizona what fight what
are you taught you lost like no I don't
know like 37 times right didn't you
you're like to save Arizona yeah is it
okay is save Arizona a phrase is it a
title of something why is the S
capitalized are we following Donald
Trump in terms of how we do grammar and
punctuation and this makes no sense I
know well she does not make any sense
she continues to say let's put it all
account no because the Judiciary and
their last ruling actually the last line
of it was was a link to don't you come
back no more no more don't you come back
no more
87 or 37 87 87 well here's the thing
into that last decision which is the
last decision she cannot appeal it
that's all [__] she can't appeal it
there's nothing else to do it says it
says Katie Hobbs is the governor of
Arizona period dummy don't you come back
no more no more don't you come back
okay so she goes on to say that means
securing our border arizonans across the
state depend on it I hope you can join
me in former ice director Tom Holmen on
May 31st for uh yeah this former ice
director Tom Homan I don't know defend
America this is tomorrow and you get
free tickets hey everybody here's free
ticket link don't go order free tickets
whatever you do do not order thousands
of free tickets don't do it you probably
shouldn't but this is the [__] what
the [__] is this what the [__] is this
what the [__] she did I thought you were
lying she [__] did it look at that
Kerry Lake Governor lie to you Tony
yeah you wouldn't mind my favorite turd
am I your favorite
slim jim Taco but I wouldn't lie to you
about this you bastard look at listen
number one why the [__] does she have
Carrie Lake on this side and then Lake
on this side that doesn't make Tony Tony
Tony okay that makes sense
Tony Tony yeah
look man you're you're spending too many
brain cells on that okay
you can't stop to think about it because
it doesn't make any sense
what the [__] is this like I want to
know like I guarantee the jacket which
looks like it's a decently high quality
jacket probably not purchased by her
it's purchased by the amount of funds
that came in to make sure that she could
fight to be Governor is this a North
Face because you know they're supposed
to be boycotting North Face because
North Face is I don't know what kind of
jacket it is honestly I think it oh my
god do y'all follow muscles in nursing
at all on Tick Tock oh my God he did a
great thing on it he's like you are not
boycotting North Face because we knew
you couldn't afford that [__] in the
first place
this morning it's Chick-fil-A which I
don't know they know this yeah they're
gonna boycott Chick-fil-A wait what hang
on let me go [__] find it I gotta
switch my account back oh my God what
are you finding that why are you finding
that the reason I mentioned Carrie Lake
there was she has some value to Trump up
she still brings in money from Papa and
crazy uncle and you know all the young
guys that for some reason are the new
neo-nazis they all still send her money
Ken Paxton doesn't really have [__] to
offer yeah Donald Trump other than he is
a competent attorney I'll give him that
much the guy doesn't lose a lot I bet
Ken Paxton has a jacket that says Ken
Paxton attorney general though that he
can wear and he could walk around and
it's like technically that's true you
know he could walk around he could be
like attorney general [__] right
attorney general [__] like it's like
whether I was the attorney general or
the former at least I'm not like why not
I mean Donald Trump walks around but
Donald Trump walks around says Donald
Trump [__] president on [__]
do these people think all she gotta do
is make a shirt and that's just that's
your job is that what they think and
Tony and while Donald Trump loves this
thing you just you just said well done
well I am this I'm in this position I am
this role I am this whatever and people
go okay well he said it enough times it
must be true must be true you know what
was that text before and while while
Donald Trump you know I mean he loves to
use people we all know he freaking hates
ugly people yeah and Ken Paxton is one
ugly some [__] man I mean yeah
well I mean that's true but I mean he is
ugly as hell he looks greasy
hello
Donald Trump probably wouldn't like the
smell if it's owed to Jack Daniels and
those are yeah and those are the
pictures he puts out right those aren't
even the ones like where we're screwing
with them you know like we take the
pictures of Donald Trump when he's out
been golfing and he's all sweaty and he
doesn't have any makeup on and he you
know he looks like hammered [__] and
this that and the other no man these are
the pictures that Ken packs let me try
to find you one these are the pictures
that Ken Paxton puts out in His official
pictures and he looks like buttered
toast smothered in Bourbon
probably smells like it too oh there's
so there's a there's a slice there's a
slight slight correction slight
correction and obviously it was done by
it was done intentionally
if you zoom in on the image get can you
give me the zoomed in like zooming in
cut it and put it on a slide so I can
show it no I'm not gonna do that
yeah
I'll click the link all right you take
your mouse and you click the link Tony
hey will you I
now and now you now you have your
pension you zoom you zoom in or you do a
little command plus you know you're on
an Apple oh my God this is
you got it it's [__] so what we're
gonna find here is if you zoom in you
scroll down no [__] way or you [__]
me the chat is saying look at look at
look how small it is but and it's it's
it's uh intentionally done that small
obviously
you might think that's some sort of
symbol or something or like a little
like squiggly or whatever it's like a
backwards Florida to be quite hairy Lake
for governor you know like
that's that's what it is uh Chef boy or
homie homeboy Chef boy or homeboy
spotted it Carrie like poor Governor
it's so it's so quiet it's like a
whisper right
four
oh my God Jesus Christ okay
um while you're finding pictures of the
bourbon toast there I'm gonna go to this
this fool this is the uh the Chick-fil-A
problem that they're having this morning
um we have a problem Joey says
Chick-fil-A just hired a VP listen to
this get this vice president of
diversity equity and inclusion all bad
words by the way none of that none of
that should be anywhere near uh
Chick-fil-A even if they decide it's
near Chick-fil-A because it's their
corporation it's their organization it's
not in public if Chick-fil-A any
publicly traded it's a private private
company this is bad very bad very
I just he goes I don't want to have a
boycott are we gonna have to have a
boycott now it gets better Gabe Sanchez
trust me this this seems really stupid
right yeah
know if Joey knows this but but the left
tried to boycott uh Chick-fil-A now
years ago because Chick-fil-A gave a lot
of money to anti-lgbtq yeah
and now now they're gonna go on about
because they think diversity Equity
inclusion actually means gay or
something I'm not sure what they think
those words mean I think they think
that's what's so stupid about this Tony
is Dei it is not quotas it is not any
all it is is making sure that you get
the word out to all communities about
what's available out there that is
really the core of Dei it's not freaking
quotas it's not EEOC you know equal
opportunity stuff none of it it's none
of that if you're Chick-fil-A and you
run restaurants little restaurants like
that you're gonna need folks
good quality folks you're going to need
from every quarter because there just
ain't enough white boys to go out there
and manage Chick-fil-A restaurants that
want to do that for a living there just
aren't you're gonna need black folks you
know what di also includes that they
that they totally [__] miss here and
and they step on the rake every time and
this d i you know the one um
marginalized group of people the DI
actually benefits more than bipoc people
or lgbtq people uh disabled people you
stupid [__] idiots d-i that is one of
the groups of people that they are
actually using Dei to to get into their
organizations is is people with
disabilities and and you [__]
boneheads are out there going d-i is bad
so you can't
you're gonna have to stop at some point
with with the wokism and the we hate
black people stuff we hate brown people
stuff because you're starting to bleed
into other communities that like the
pro-life movement and everything else
has always been like oh yeah let's this
is insane well like I mean it's so
[__] the Republic they're Republicans
oh oh Hey listen this tweet gets better
this tweak I know you don't think it can
get better I can't wait to read the next
part that Joey tweeted to be quite
honest it's a hell of a quote here's his
follow-up okay because he's giving the
chick-fil-a.com link for diversity
equity and inclusion on their website
right this guy's out there searching on
the internet here's what he tweets about
that link this is his [__] words not
mine
it's only a matter of time until they
start putting [__] semen in the
Frosted lemonade at this point this is a
really weird that this guy jumps from di
to putting semen in his frosted lemonade
this is really weird yeah oh okay first
off uh I didn't even know they had
Frosted lemonade and now I kind of want
to try it not to say that there's semen
in it but it's also weird because
the immediate jump that they go oh
they're supporting they they have a
position for Dei
and then the jump
from di boycott [__] are gonna put
semen in frozen lemonade how do you even
make that connection because they're
mine I know I know how [__] messed up
their mind is but you go from a to like
God okay I guess you want to boycott it
that's fine but then you go from A to B
B being we should boycott and then C
Bean the next thing is they're semen and
it's like dude okay why are you still
thinking about this quit being so nice
about it Gabe quit being so nice about
it we're having a discussion over here
about recruiting the best candidates
from everywhere
and that immediately sends this guy to
thinking about dick
not only this guy wants to drink come
Joey loves come with the lemonade I
would say it's even further it's it's
Joey's insecure feelings knowing that
that trans person has a bigger dick than
him that could be he's got a pole here
and I'm not saying oh my God he's got a
boy
likes so I told you I told you listen
listen listen it says okay y'all so
what's the consensus he's gonna do a
Twitter poll and this is gonna determine
whether they boycott
um semen in their frozen lemonade or not
apparently uh we are boycotting
Chick-fil-A over this yes or no because
he's again yes or no he's he's saying
are we gonna boycott them over putting
semen in frosted lemonade let's find out
I'm gonna vote here I'm gonna vote here
sure let's boycott him
oh he's losing big time who is Joe
manorino Joe Mannarino is um and he's
probably uh oh you see Mario evolves him
he's been in Mario's rooms that's
probably what it is pronouns shut up
okay it's kiss my ass man don't you know
the problems for the for the [__] the
[__] eaters out there [__] eaters
pronouns are [__] eater [__] off and
then kiss my ass right oh God why does
it not say there that he likes dick I
don't know because it should I mean
because
how do you get from a conversation about
Dei and what Dei is to dick I mean I
really want to know
and beyond that [__] in my lemonade
you know I mean
isn't in my lemonade is where he went I
mean let's say it out loud folks let's
really talk about these people and what
they are he is going from let's recruit
competent people from all segments of
society to hey wank one off in my
lemonade won't you listen that's where
his mind went I'm not gonna shame anyone
who wants some some some uh some baby
batter in their lemonade because you
know you do you whatever you want to do
if you want to order a lemonade from
China guys guys I'm sorry
I'm doing research into Joe manarino and
I just I just hold on because he says
it's free your voice America please play
this video is this oh this is on YouTube
this is Joe Mannarino
singing
hang on I gotta get through the um whoa
whoa oh yeah
this is about to be the most tone deaf
terrible karaoke session you've ever
heard here we go foreign
yeah baby
this really has I I gotta say I gotta
say so far this really has a come
lemonade type you know dude there's so
much oh he's he's like definitely loves
he definitely loves baby batteries
phallic yeah it does is he gonna is he
gonna what's he gonna do here I'm just
saying I listen to about 15 seconds of
it and it was like I'm glorious okay
let's keep let's see let's see how great
of a singer he is let's see if he's
let's see if he's better at singing than
he is at boycotting
yeah
[Music]
this guy's definitely 100 this guy this
guy this guy drinks drinks gum
oh God [__] damn oh my God I mean he
kind of he kind of does he looks like a
pie [__] foreign
man you just you I don't know Texas Paul
I think what was it last week or the
week before we had like the best show
ever I don't know this this one I don't
know this is me this is me uh and I am
now going to do oh what was that on this
[__]
I just want to say imagine being this
guy is my Michael okay can you hear me
okay I haven't deep throated my mic
before I mean
for everything for anyone listening to
the audio you gotta come watch the video
at about a minute 20. all right an hour
20 excuse me Jesus Christ
you gotta come watch the video at about
an hour 20. please someone out there
clip this and put this on [__]
Twitter if you put this on Twitter and
you totally you totally will get a
retweet from me game and Texas Paul no
question
can you sticking his microphone in his
[__] mouth
can you imagine like being this guy's
insurance agent
okay Joey here we go we've got your
policy laid out right here we got all
your cars covered here here's your
rental insurance it's in there and
Joey's like
but aren't you gonna jerk off on it
you're just going to hand me
hand me up what are you doing
I had no idea where you where you're
going I mean you know they they do say
that some deals are signed in blood but
for Joey they're signing semen they're
signed into a perfect perfect that's why
I love Gabe
oh I I can't even get over that the song
that Joey's saying here is called desire
it's called desire even Joey man dude
look all I'm saying is I got this plane
in the background right now
oh Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey
Joey because he he's following 24 000
people and he's got he's got 166. oh you
want me to look up at the bottom ah yeah
let's see how many uh because if if his
uh YouTube skills are any indication of
his followers skills these are
definitely fake he's got four
subscriptions by the way whoo baby oh
man four people
yeah his four other soccer counts that
he's got right I mean what is he doing
his socks probably Texas Paul oh they're
pretty stiff so do they
that dude crunches when he walks
[Music]
[__] idiots right I mean here's
another one coming out of the woodwork
we're gonna make this guy [__] famous
oh Tony watch what you say man would
work we're gonna we're gonna make this
guy [__] famous
um because he's such a Ding-A-Ling and
let me tell you something Republican
party please please if you'll do
anything for me this year please put
Joey out front please make Jilly your
[__] your your new spokesperson that
would be fantastic if you do that and I
can't wait I can't wait to see Joey in
one of Mario's rooms because I'm gonna
ask him about deep throating the
microphone on his song Desire that's
that's fantastic and um maybe maybe me
and Joey could have like a karaoke
um um Sing-Off or something I don't know
I'm just
oh my God
Joey and again just to reiterate what
Tony said earlier we don't care what
your freak is here right we care that
you go from absolutely normal [__] to
getting your freak on in inappropriate
places like Joni manorino or Joey
manorio or whatever the hell ever his
name is oh my God boy okay I'm doing it
I'm doing it could you imagine that guy
if you ever like got elected to congress
yes we would like to talk about defense
spending and uh do we need more the new
variant of Abram's tanks is that in the
other
point of order allow me to take my penis
out
um
yes we we need to discuss how much semen
can we actually put on this tank for it
to still function
I mean we know that it's going I mean
every damn conversation with these
freaking perverts in a moment of
seriousness they're freaking sick man
every conversation a little kid and
Target you know we're going to give them
a rainbow shirt because you know they
know they're gay I hate to tell you
folks in the churches and [__] your kid
knows if they're gay or not you know so
Target offers in the shirt that says hey
it's okay if you're gay man it's all
right you be you you're going to be
great
immediately go to genitals
do they go to gym it's a weird it's a
weird flight sex too
sex 100 go right to there uh I can tell
you also as I'm doing as you guys are
talking and I'm doing a little
background research on Joey Joey sounds
exactly like you think Joey would sound
like like the singing was God awful but
when he talks on a podcast
no it's not it well I guess kind of oh
wait is it more is it more like he likes
semen in his lemonade it sounds like
there's like something in his mouth oh
okay
no he's able to still speak with it oh
it just sounds like there's a I don't
know he's he's juggling I gotcha so
speaking of uh boycotts and I hate to
move on but
um because I would love to just keep
pounding away at Joey um
um Texas ball brought up Target
and Fox News decoding Fox News actually
has a great clip here
um she posted last week Fox promoted the
idea that Target was selling satanic
clothing to children and Tuck friendly
bathing suits in child sizes neither is
true uh it's the latest version of
satanic panic and this is this is their
MO this is what Joey's trying to do with
a semen lemonade he's like oh he should
be scared of semen lemonade is what we
should do it sounds delicious but we
should be scared
um I actually went to Target last night
I mentioned this in the a block oh
that's organization dude that's pretty
gay I did well I went to Target I I
stopped off at Chick-fil-A had one of
them um them semen lemonades and then I
bought Bud Light and drank all the Bud
Light by the time I got out of the
targets to make sure I was full on
homosexual and I'm just kidding we went
to the pride section now the pride
section our Target was like where the
seasonal stuff is which is where I'm
guessing all the pride sections are
because it's I don't no it's pride month
so it's like a seasonal thing now in the
in in this section all the stuff was
highly offensive especially if you're
offended by rainbows at all or colors if
you do not like colors of the rainbow
this is going to terrify you in this
section now one thing that I want to
point out there was one of the
indoctrination suits that uh for a baby
it was a there's a little baby outfit it
was like shorts overalls you know
coveralls you know what I'm talking
about the Texas ball coveralls they they
were they were black but they it was
total indoctrination because on those
overalls as kids overalls it had a
rainbow which immediately is satanic
okay with the rainbow and then under it
with the words be kind can you believe
that can you believe the outrage that I
must have had when I found out that
people are buying children's outfits
number one on the rainbows on them but
then the words be kind holy [__] what
are you trying to indoctrinate children
to do have empathy Jesus [__] Christ
we can't have these kids running around
to have empathy and Fox News they had a
lot of lies to say about it too let's
hear it coming up Target pull the Bud
Light and partnered with a trans
Satanist
an it doesn't take a PR expert to know
that if you hire a Satanist to design a
children's clothing line and you stock
your shelves with tuck friendly bathing
suits people will get upset very upset
the only only you are upset be very
clear are the ones putting Satan
respects pronouns on children's clothing
thought it was a good idea to put a
Satanist clothing line in their story is
that Tommy Lauren yeah yeah I I didn't
know she got gender relative surgery I
yeah well you can tell
um I'm just saying if we're gonna if
we're gonna come at people for getting
surgery still look a certain way that
they feel comfortable with she's the
first one on the list right also so is
Kaylee mcinany technically both of them
did you know they look like they have
had a gender affirming uh surgeries well
you know I I didn't know I actually just
want to point this out if people don't
know this so Kaylee mcanany she uh
before she came into office in the Trump
Administration yeah she had a mass that
was detected and she got a double
mastectomy okay
so she got her breasts removed whoa whoa
whoa did she have fake breasts and now
she has fake breasts that's not cool at
all that's Titanic too yeah so I'm just
saying if we're gonna if we're gonna let
allow Republicans to come after others
for for getting something that isn't
natural in their bodies to look a
certain way
because they want to feel comfortable
which again nothing wrong with that
but if you're gonna attack people then
people should know
that they're all Hypocrites we should
have both of them on that show are
hypocrites right now we should be
inclusive to be quite honest
you're right well no I'm saying if we're
going to be inclusive and they're gonna
have their their hatred they should be
inclusive with their hatred and they
could they should spread it around a bit
is all I'm saying okay let's continue
with the two non-relevant
um folks here on the screen is it good
for business well here's another one I
could have closed design Audi really by
yourself proclaimed Satanist this guy
that guy looks I'm Satanist what does
this guy even look I'm a Walmart
Anderson Cooper
Walmart that's insulting Walmart really
I think I'm a Dollar Tree Dollar Tree
really wish.com maybe wish
Store Anderson Cooper
oh my God Texas father you got to dig
there is I know you want to get one in
on tree Gowdy
oh man I just actually I was thinking
about I got lost and thought on
something else it's just been I'm
actually gonna do a show on it here and
then maybe I'll do it on tomorrow show I
don't know
but this isn't this isn't organic this
comes from you know I I've said this
before there's no training program for
billionaires there isn't
you know if a lot of millionaires are
sociopaths when they get this money
there is no training program for them to
say hey you know what you might be
Seventh-day Adventist like like oh
Ferris Wilkes is here in Texas he he's
one of the oligarchs that funds all of
this [__]
you know this doesn't pay for itself
folks I mean this astro turf we gotta
hate Target [__] ain't free
guys like Ferris Wilkes are
massive Christo fascists you know
there's a big push to in public
education here in the state of Texas
they want it to be all Christian schools
that comes from Ferris Wilkes why
because he was a religious freak
his entire life and when he became a
billionaire
in his Twisted ass mind
he believes that was a reward from God
for being a religious freak and
therefore it's his mission to push his
religious freedom on everybody
so they are funding this [__]
the hate of the lgbtq committee isn't
just a you know the Republican Party
woke up one day and said you know if we
hate on these folks maybe we'll do okay
at the polls no man no this is really
funded by people that have been pulling
the Republican party right another one
here in Texas is Tim Dunn another guy
pastor at his church and all this other
[__] he's an ultra Christian nationalist
trying to destroy public education when
he got his money
there was no training program for him to
say hey him buddy we know you think what
you think but there's a lot of people in
the world that don't think like you so
maybe you just do you boo boo no there
is no training for these people like
that they think that they were rewarded
by God
and they should use everything they got
from God to force God on us
they really believe that is their life's
Mission now and they do it through
institutes they do it through
foundations they do it and and here in
Texas we've had like crazy conservatives
I mean really serious conservatives that
dared say hey you know what dude
um
maybe we should leave public education
alone
because we need to educate our people if
we want to have a strong Workforce this
and the other
and Tim Dunn paid the primary that
[__]
he did he did he primaried him from the
right
that just was not okay
I mean and Dade Fallon the drunk that's
Tim Dunn's guy
that's that's his guy
because you know of course Dade Fallon
is such a great Christian
you know he's just a great Christian
you know and and Tim Dunn owns him Lock
Stock and Barrel that's why they do this
[__] that's why they say this [__]
says uh Nazi theocrats and that's that's
correct sounds about white to me sounds
I think you're I think you're onto
something there
what's the Instagram thing you sent me
okay so I I wanted to make a quick uh
just a little this is a real-time fact
check okay
Fox News wants to talk about how all of
these items at Target are made by some
Satanist right so for people who don't
know the Satanist in question that
they're talking about right didn't
design all of the pride gear okay
they designed one item or one line of
item right they were contacted by Target
and so the artist is Eric Carnell who is
a
a transgender designer okay
and if you go to that post the post
explains in there and I can I can read
it Well here here's here's the here's
the uh the picture this is what
triggered Republicans to think that that
this artist was a satanistan and in the
description
uh Eric says one of my favorite most
popular designs and the one that gave
eprellin the brand uh proper footing
Direction coming up with the phrase
really helped people or really make a
problem what it is today which is Satan
respects pronouns okay and in that
description he says Satan loves you and
respects who you are you're important
and valuable in this world and you
deserve to be treated with love and
respect LGBT plus people are so often
referred to as a product of Satan or
going against God's will so fine we'll
hang with Satan instead
and then said satanists don't actually
believe in Satan he is merely used as a
symbol of passion pride and Liberty he
means to you what you need him to mean
so for you Satan is Hope compassion
equality blah blah Satan respects
pronouns he loves the LGBT plus people
uh I spent the variation of
uh but FEMA for his design design a
deity who themselves is a mixture of
genders beings ideas and existences they
reject binary stereotypes and
expectations perfect now this is the
thing that [__] threw them off to go
crazy and say that everything in in the
pride section was made by a Satanist
it's not actually true so what actually
what actually was the design that they
were they were yeah they were like a
fanny pack and whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
wait a second fanny pack it was uh yeah
let me let me that sounds demonic in and
of itself it was sorry it was uh
the the satanish
let me tell you why that plays into this
so perfectly for guys like Ferris Wilkes
that guy that [__] guy is a
Seventh-Day Adventist they believe in
the into they don't they're not like
Jesus followers they like all 66 books
of the Bible you have to follow them all
they're the Leviticus people they're the
you know what I mean they are really
out there so
this guy believes as his church does
that the government is satanic
and and infiltrated by demons and that
they will defeat the government and
create a government in its place
of good Christian people
this is his core religious belief is it
the same Shaman the ramen Shaman
bobert's boyfriend oh man they are just
a out there they're not there's a reason
folks that the Branch Davidians were
here in Texas I mean there is a reason I
mean there there is a group of people
here in Texas that will believe
crazy [__] and these Seventh-Day
Adventists really really really believe
that they are going to have a war with
our government that is controlled by
Satan and bring in Christianity and they
see something like this where targets
got a guy that's joking
it's it's it's a freaking joke this dude
is not a Satan boy he's mocking
Christians is what he's doing he's
exacting Christians like in your book it
says it says to love everyone and that's
not what you're doing so because that's
not what you're doing I'm gonna do the
opposite and mock you with Satan right
and so the items that were pulled from
the shelves was a was uh one of which
was including a fanny pack with swirling
planets that reads we belong everywhere
crazy
sounds that's a minute and then a tote
bag with the UFO that proclaims too
queer for here this is
how these people this is what these
people these crazy right-wing religious
but they're not actually religious
extremists
said to to to Target as they're
threatening the lives of target
employees people who are like man I'm
just here for a [__] seasonal job I'm
a teenager working here while I'm on
break I'm someone who's in between jobs
and I'm just here for the [__] season
because I don't know if those people
know this but these places hire seasonal
employees right they're like ah we don't
need everyone to be full-time we'll hire
you for the Christmas season
Thanksgiving season the summer season
whatever it might be
and you have these products which again
are seasonal they might have some that
are like
want to spread love and kindness you
know that are just like generic t-shirts
or clothing items that are there
but there are seasonal things like you
pointed out there's a seasonal section
and in there is for pride parade which
is happening throughout the month of
June
so you have these people that are full
on threatening the lives because
you can't just boycott you have to
threaten people's livelihood as well as
their actual existence right not just
like oh I hate trans people I hate gay
people whatever it's like no I just hate
you as a human and I hope something bad
happens to you it's insane it's insane
that that we have to live with these
types of people but they get so
triggered off the simplest things like
[__] swirling planets on a fanny pack
or a UFO on a [__] tote bag no one
made you buy that no one made you buy no
one's making you go into a Target either
and no one's making your kid buy it you
know like it's it's this it's the
fear-mongering it's the thing that it
will be right but it never is in
existence
but Gabe they don't go and they tell
their people you know like you know
the the this billionaire is not funding
for them to go tell people you know you
don't have to buy this [__] it's just
it's you know no they're they're writing
this up as Target intentionally is
trying to turn your kid trans right and
everybody I talked to when I pointed out
that hey you know what Walmart's work
too
every one of the responses were but
Walmart didn't go after kids
well neither did Target that that
everything you showed there were and it
was an adult sizes right
you know what I mean they didn't Target
your kids or when they're talking about
oh we've got these uh the items for
tucking right and you're like that's a
child's outfit that's a [__] child's
outfit that is not meant for an adult
that is someone if you're like oh I'm
talking because I don't know they might
wear a [__] diaper or it's easy to
take on and off because I've got a
[__] change a child
but they're like oh no look at these
tucking items and it's like for children
for children these aren't adults okay
it's like okay
this is this is the [__] that gets me
the most because I was in the pride
display last night and I was there with
my daughter right and she was looking at
stuff and there was stuff in there that
she was reading that I wasn't offended
that she was reading because they're
words and me and her were talking about
the stuff that was in there she's gonna
be nine June 1st she's gonna be nine
she's fine she was okay my daughter did
not leave the pride thing and be gay
because you're you're either born
straight you're born gay it's a spectrum
you're you're born that way sometimes
you're experience in life may open up
things in your mind that you didn't know
that you had and that is what they're
really [__] frustrated about they're
really frustrated because all the
billionaires that you were talking about
text Paul they're probably all closeted
homosexuals that's one of the things
that fear makes him fear the most about
about their sexuality because they're
[__] insecure
and they target their hatred towards
what they're insecure about that's what
it is that's what it is it's what it's
always been you don't you don't turn gay
because you drink a beer you don't turn
gay because you see a [__] rainbow
you don't turn gay because someone's
like hey you should be gay listen
conversion therapy conversion therapy
doesn't work there's a reason why it
doesn't work one way and it doesn't work
the other way you can't turn someone gay
you can't do it it's not a thing just
like you can't undo someone who is gay
it's their sexuality it's them it's
their experience it's their mind it's
who they are and everything is okay if
they are that way there's nothing wrong
with it no one's gonna [__] with you if
you don't stop [__] with people
though we are going to smash your
[__] hatred your [__] bigotry and
your your [__] fascism off this
[__] planet I am sick and tired of
these [__] I don't care if they
got money or they got a tick tock
account going after the American people
they're [__] countrymen who did
nothing to them not a goddamn thing
other than be themselves and want to be
themselves so shut the [__] up with your
hatred and your bigotry no one's turning
you gay and if you're scared if you're
terrified that someone's gonna turn you
or your kids gay you have an insecurity
about your sexuality it may not be that
you are gay but you definitely have an
insecurity about it for sure 100 just
like the guy at the bar several weeks
ago when I ordered a Bud Light he was
behind me and he said would you order a
skirt with that I turned around and
looked him in the eyes I said what are
you scared this beer is going to turn
you gay
and he [__] had a Blank Stare on his
face I took a big drink I said boy it
makes me want to [__] a dude now
they gotta stop this [__] and the only
way to do it is yell and scream and
[__] get loud and support people out
there that that are part of this
community or Allies in this community
stop with the hatred and bigotry stop at
the dumb [__] I'm not people don't
buy into this [__] they just don't I
mean yeah a certain population that are
dumber than dog [__] but they'll buy
anything like Texas Paul said they'll
[__] buy any stupid idea that that's
out there
but Tony you've got to go after the
churches you have to go after the
churches that's what they're running
this [__] through gay conversion therapy
where does that come from church
Church churches they they are running
this and everybody's like well don't
attack Christianity don't attack
no man you these really radical freaks
out there that have been funding Texas
politics and politics in general across
the world are not your daddy's Christian
they are not they don't go to school or
go to church and come out and say well
we got to love everybody no no that is
not what these people are and they're
funding it through your churches because
they your pastor smells the power your
pastor in your church that you think is
good-natured and great your pastor
smells the power and he knows that that
guys like Tim Dunn guys like Ferris
Wilkes are funding this [__]
and they're marrying the churches and
politics and your pastor knows that at
the other end of that rainbow rainbow
pun intended is power for them
so they're marrying on they're dragging
your church into this [__] so yeah we
have to look at your church now you have
my attention you have my attention when
you go after gay people and you go after
trans people transgender people that
aren't doing anything in their damn
lives because you're trying to scare the
[__] out of people and you'd lie to them
and tell them oh they're coming after
your kids what they're freaking out
about is that more kids than ever have
come out and identified as lgbtq plus
that terrifies them they're like if
you're not indoctrinating why does that
happen oh I don't know maybe because we
said you're a sorry piece of [__]
because you supported what happened to
Matthew Shepard you know when Matthew
Shepard came out as gay they took him
out into a goddamn Montana field and
beat him to death and tied him up into a
goddamn barbed wire fence that used to
happen
now gay people feel more safe
gay people feel more accepted so they
come out
so they come out they were always there
you [__]
but they were terrified of you
and what I'm saying is your church isn't
safe
your church isn't safe for for Americans
your church is full of pedophiles
your kids aren't safe in your church I
didn't come to your church you brought
your church into my politics
so now you have my attention and your
church is going to lose because of these
radical ass people like Ferris Wilkes
that believes that they've got some holy
freaking war to fight and now he's a
goddamn billionaire and he's making your
pastor have a freaking hard on for some
donations and some power
this is on you
not me I didn't come for you you came
for us
there's a clip from 2006 of Lewis Black
and I'm probably gonna get knocked on
YouTube for playing this but um I'm
gonna play it anyways uh Lewis Black
this is 2006 folks I don't know if you
can do the math but that's many years
ago of Lewis Black saying uh this
religious attack on gay people and
hatred gay people is really [__]
stupid and he gives you some funny
laughs of wine let's listen
you can go ahead and think it that's
fine but you don't say aloud that
homosexuality is a threat to the
American family because that's that's
prejudice
that's that's complete and utter
Prejudice and ignorance on a level
that's staggering at this point in time
it's very similar to the prejudice
from space when you thought that uh
during the first night of passover that
we would go into the Christian Community
and kidnap it the firstborn of Christian
families and tell it
and that for those who don't realize is
[__]
he would be kidnapped the child will
make them work for us and that's a big
difference
[Applause]
homosexuality is the threat to the
American family are you kidding me
well how no one ever explains it how
it's not like there's a Jehovah's
Witnesses of datum
hi we're here and we're queer we're here
and we're queer
I brought swatches I brought swatches
[Music]
but maybe I'm wrong maybe there are a
group of Dave and Peter
[Laughter]
who got into a van every day
I've heard from Village to Dell
hike begins to fall
they go back into a Suburban
neighborhood can I call this act where
only one house stands and in the window
Young American family is just setting
down for their first meal for these
Queens
it's quick God
that black cloaks and hoods and matching
pumps very cases
[Applause]
they Circle up their faces
sneak up to that house and open the door
and start [__] each other they are
[Laughter]
and another American family is destroyed
and you couldn't say it any better
because that just is not happening but
that is the imagery that they're trying
to portray right like again when I went
in to Target last night there was
several little child children like baby
outfits and again the one that they
would be offended by it had a rainbow on
it with two clowns on the side which I
had no idea was the rainbows were
demonic I I hadn't got that memo
um but underneath the rainbow was the
words be kind and that's what they're
saying is the indoctrination is that if
you be kind then you'll be gay if you be
kind and you'd be kind to gay people and
that's what they're really terrified of
Texas Paul that's what you're saying at
a level is that they don't want you to
be kind your goal is not to be kind in
this in this white Christian nationalism
it is to hate it is to perpetuate your
hatred it is too it is to advance your
hatred towards the other whoever the
other is and right now the other is
trans people people and it just starts
to incorporate all kinds of people with
trans people and and and and the lgbtq
community and then all all the Allies oh
well there's a lot of women allies up
women are in the group too so their
level of hatred is is to continue it to
perpetuate it just like Lewis Black said
in 2006 what the [__] are you talking
about there is not a gay Brigade
that is going out and indoctrinating
people and knocking on doors they're
certainly Christians there's certainly
churches that leave leaflets on in
underneath windshield wipers they knock
on your doors they go from neighborhood
to neighborhood they send you mailers in
the mail telling you to come attend
their Church to come and ten attend
their indoctrination hatred centers
um but they just don't exist in the
lgbtq Tony
I think we're losing your honor oh no oh
they're very it's the queers man where's
it coming after them I think that's what
it was we played Lewis Black in the word
queer the gay Brigade is that what he
said no Gabe van D what do you say gay
band I think it was gay bandito
I think it was gay Banditos Texas Paul
is frozen oh no no there he is there he
is he's back he's back what were you
gonna say
it's the schools Tony that's what
they're telling them it's the schools
that are indoctrinating that's why
you've got putting fingers over there
trying to to to
strip out the libraries that's why you
know they are preaching it's the schools
doing the recruiting
we really are and that's and Tony it's
not just these radicals anymore they
have told regular old churches if you
drive down the street Tony you're in
Missouri you know you're in the Bible
belt buckle
there are churches you could can't throw
a rock without hitting one
and every one of those churches is
preaching right now the gospel of public
education is being used to indoctrinate
your children the satanists have taken
over public education and they are
making your children gay
I want to give you some hope here Texas
Paul because there's um there's actually
um you know the Methodist Church the
United Methodist Church they're actually
and for years they've been at odds
because there's a faction of the United
Methodist Church that believes exactly
what you're saying that believes that
they should hate people believes that
the hatred is what God and Jesus would
want and there's a faction of the United
Methodist Church that is not for that
that is the exact opposite they believe
in inclusion they believe in diversity
they believe
in love they believe in being kind and
Christianity and you know like what
would Jesus do type stuff so there is
hope out there for for maybe not
Christianity as a whole but maybe people
who still have some Faith right
um that want to believe that that the
Jesus that is in the Bible in the second
half of the Bible may love everyone like
it says they do and I'm an atheist
so I I don't I don't believe in the
Hokum of religion in general not just
Christianity but I I will I will say
there are there are factions of churches
out there and the Methodist Church
actually is going through a process
where they want to divide up and the
reason why is because the one faction
wants to hate
the other the other action just wants to
you know preach the the Bible and and
love and and be members of the community
the other faction wants to hate they
want to actually hate and have a place
where they can hate people which is
weird that and and if you go look at
some of the stories on the Methodist
Church and how they're breaking up it
really describes it really describes how
why young people aren't interested in
what you're saying churches in
Christianity in general but I think the
answer to this and a lot of people say
this I think the answer to this is to
tax the churches but we have to have a
lot of people in Congress folks we're
going to have to engage in our democracy
for many many more years to get in a
position where we can actually tax out
the hate
um which I think we can actually do we
can tax out the hate in these churches
because we can just tax them out of
existence
um if if they engage in political
activity especially if they engage in
what seems to be hate speech then then
they can be taxed out of existence and
then I think that's what we should do if
you're if you're using your church as a
political arm
um to interject your political policies
and your beliefs into what we have is
the separation of church and state by
our constitution I believe we can do
that that is all the time that we have
oh God I wish we could settle this today
but Texas Paul I don't think we're going
to uh Texas Paul give us a Shameless
plug I got Texas police link down in the
description it's real Texas Paul not
comments realtexaspoll.com tell us about
your show Texas ball
yep we've expanded out there was a big
cry from the from the crowd we you know
we've been picking up subscribers it's
growing growing like gangbusters Tony we
were doing a Sunday show everybody said
we want more so now I'm going to do a
Wednesday show that is going to throw
directly into your audience I'm gonna
we're gonna have to get together after
the show and talk about this because I
want to do a throw at the end of the
show directly into the Tony Michaels
show we're going to cut it off about
we're going to cut it off about five
minutes early to have people give them a
chance hit the bathroom click over to
your show get the feed going I've got
Mrs Texas Paul has her links ready to go
and if you guys want to feed me some
taco topics or something like that on
Wednesdays I will be more than happy to
throw to your show awesome that sounds
[__] fantastic Gabe Sanchez you have
any what was that's coming up uh yeah
I've got uh I'm actually after this I'm
gonna film what was that about Lauren
bobert and her hypocrisy because
yesterday she made a video on Memorial
Day being like we have to thank our the
you know support unwavering support of
our veterans and our troops [__] that
[__] that [__] she's she's a [__]
liar so I go through the receipts I call
her out all that stuff and then of
course our boy Joey manorino I gotta do
a what was that oh yeah you've already
decided boycott called for [__]
Chick-fil-A and the ridiculous of it so
expect those two will come and I got Ted
Cruz coming on I got a uh Ron DeSantis
one coming a lot on the plates all these
sound like rake steppers to be quite
nice
every single day they're stepping on
rates and I got news for you the
audience out there the call for let them
meet rake merch it's on store not the
Tony michaels.com that's right store not
the Tony michaels.com you can get a let
them eat rake t-shirt right now just go
to
store.thetonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com click the merch
store there and go get get your T-shirt
we'll have hoodies we'll have stickers
we'll release this stuff over this week
and I'll let you know so keep an eye out
for the products that you want with the
latte meat rake design on it we're so
happy with this rake design it turned
out just like we wanted it and honestly
what you should be doing right now if
you're not doing it already is subscribe
to the YouTube channel here on the Tony
Michaels podcast because you can watch
us every single weekday Live on YouTube
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
download every single audio version of
the podcast in the afternoon on Apple
Spotify and Google you can watch did you
know this game says you can watch our
show live on Facebook every single every
single day if you want to go to at the
Tony Michaels just go to Tony Michaels
on Facebook follow us there you can
watch the show there also I want to
thank everyone who has re-subscribed
today on Twitch and given us a new
subscription with prime folks if you
want to use your Prime account to give
us two dollars and seven cents I think
is about the the money that we get if
you want to use your Prime account to
give us two bucks a month all you got to
do is link your Prime account to a
Twitch account subscribe with that one
free subscription on Twitch with your
Prime account and we get a couple bucks
each month here's what I'll tell you
down in the description below there is
directions on how to do it our great
moderator Mighty librarian put them
together for us she did a great job go
check out the instructions on how to
link your Prime account and your Twitch
account to give us that one free
subscription also if you want to go to
the Tony michaels.com you can find the
link there just click on link Amazon and
twitch and you'll find it there boy this
has been a great show I had no idea we
were going to talk about
all the stuff that we talked about I
almost cried laughing so hard about the
semen lemonades um
I didn't see it coming
same time same place tomorrow serves up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon